- I'm in New York city's own creative,
"Everybody loves Raymond", Phil Rosenthal
give it up.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly trumpets)
I'm your hype girl.
(Phil laughs)
What better way to celebrate the city
than with a game about
it's best foods people?
'Cause I like food.
It's time for Pizza, Bagel,
Deli, Phillip versus Kelly.
♪ Pizza, Bagel Deli,
Phillip versus Kelly ♪
But we need a host.
So let's see if we can get
somebody from New York on
the line to host this thing.
Hello? Are you there?
- [Robert] Hello? Are you,
are you talking to me? Hello.
- I couldn't hear you. Hello.
- [Robert] Are you talking to me?
- Wait, you sound familiar.
I know that voice, is this Robert De Niro?
- [Robert] No, just,
just, just call me Bobby.
It's fine. Just call me Bobby.
- Bobby. Does that sound familiar?
You think he sounds...
That's Robert De Niro. That's Bobby.
- Really?
(audience and Kelly laughing)
- [Robert] I'm watching
you Phil. I'm watching you.
It's all right.
- Start the game.
- Start the game. I love
it, I love it, I love it.
All right.
Well anyway, so thank you so
much for hosting today, Bobby.
Could you tell us how the game works?
- [Robert] Yes, sure.
On your board there
you've got 12 questions about
pizza, bagels, and delis.
(all laughing)
- [Robert] Phil and Kelly
stop laughing, Phil.
(Phil laughing)
- Phil and Kelly will take
turns selecting a square.
Now the higher the points
on the square you know
the harder the question.
So this game is played the time
but nobody knows how much time,
you know it could end at any moment.
If I catch my drift,
Phil knows what I mean.
It's lights out.
So choose your squares wisely.
(audience laughing)
You understand me?
Now Phil,
you're playing for the left
side of the house seats
and Kelly for the right
and the winner gets, you know,
something for the troubles
and they win a prize for their sides.
- So who goes first?
- [Phil] You.
- [Robert] Okay, well, Kelly you go first.
Choose your square. Go ahead.
- Okay, I'm gonna go for pizza for 400
- [Phil] Wow.
- [Robert] Pizza for 400. Okay.
- I like guts. You got guts.
- [Robert] That's
enough, Phill. Pipe down.
(Kelly chuckles)
- [Robert] Okay. In the movie,
"Elf" which I wasn't in,
Santa Claus says the
real original Ray's pizza
is on what Greenwich village street?
- Oh my gosh.
- [Robert] That's not the right answers-
- That is not.
On Suntans 42nd Street. 42nd street.
(buzzer beeps)
- [Robert] Wow.
- I don't know.
(Kelly chuckles)
- [Robert] Unfortunately, you're wrong.
- Oh yep, yep.
- [Robert] You're very wrong.
The answer we're looking for is 11th.
Go ahead Phil. Pick something.
- I'll do a bagels for 400.
- [Robert] Right, Bagels.
Okay, here we go.
What iconic New York city bagel baker
has the motto, "Like no
other bagel in the world."
That's their motto in case
you didn't get that part.
- H&H?
- [Robert] That's correct.
You're right.
(buzzer dings)
- What?
Urgh, I feel like I'm at a
disadvantage here people.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
- I'm sorry Kelly.
This is what I do.
- [Robert] Okay, Kelly
go ahead. Pick a square.
Okay. I'm gonna go pizza for a thou...
No, no, no.
- Do it.
- No I'm gonna go pizza for 200.
- [Robert] Pizza for 200. Okay.
There's pizza. Here's-
I wanted to be bold.
- [Robert] Right, what is,
what is the least popular day
of the year for pizza orders?
- Oh, Monday.
(buzzer beeps)
- [Robert] Sorry, Kelly.
That was not the answer
we were looking for.
- Is it like, there's not a day.
Is that a trick question,
'cause everybody loves pizza all the time?
- [Robert] No, it was
Thanksgiving. That's the day.
- Oh, I thought you were
asking like a day. Oh.
- Give her another one.
- No, it's fine Phil. Go.
- [Robert] Go ahead, Phil.
- Deli for 400.
- [Robert] All right, deli
for 400. Okay. Here we go.
In "Harry met Sally", she's
another movie I wasn't in.
It's ridiculous.
Meg Ryan said "Yes, yes, yes."
You know, she's having some sexual thing.
In what New York city deli
did Meg Ryan say, "Yes, yes, yes."
- This is too easy. This is Tat's Deli.
It was?
(buzzer dings)
Thank you.
I actually didn't remember that
but I do remember the scene very well.
- [Robert] You're good.
- Says every woman.
- We actually made my
first food and travel show,
"I'll Have What Phil's
Having" after that long.
(clock timer blares)
- Oh, good God, thank you.
I think we have a winner now, don't we?
Let's end this for me.
- Wow, this is quite a game-
- Yeah, yeah.
- Thank you.
And to have Robert De
Niro hosting is really...
That's a coup, to get him.
(Kelly chuckles)
- All right, so Phill ended up winning
so that means everybody
on Phil's side is a winner
but you know what?
It's 2020 and this whole year sucks.
So we all deserve a trophy.
That means everyone's getting
a $200 gift card to Lulus.
You're welcome.
(crowd cheering)
- [Phil] That's nice.
- [Kelly] They make
affordable luxury of reality
with all sorts of fresh
and polarity looks.
They're curated selections
of quality pieces at reasonable prices
coupled with superior customer service.
Will have you styled for any occasion.